[Music]
this is a very famous cautionary Tale in
math known as moser's Circle problem
some of you may have seen this before
but what I want to do here is really
explain what's going on
the way this starts is we take a circle
and put two points on that Circle and
connect them with a line that is a chord
of the circle and note that it divides
the circle into two different regions if
I add a third point and then connect
that to the previous two points with two
more chords then these lines all divide
the circle into four separate regions
then if you add a fourth point and
connect that to the previous three and
you play the same game you count up how
many regions has this cut the circle
into you end up with eight add a fifth
point to the circle connect it to the
previous four count up the total number
of regions and if you're careful with
your counting you'll get a total of 16.
naturally you can guess what might come
next but would You Bet Your Life on it
at a sixth Point connect it to all the
previous ones and if you carefully count
up all the different regions you end up
not with the power of two you might have
expected but just one shy of it
some of you might be raising your hand
saying doesn't it depend on where we put
the points for example watch how this
middle region disappears if I place
everything nice and symmetrically around
the circle so yes it does depend but
we're going to consider the cases where
you never have any three lines
intersecting with each other this would
be the generic case if you just choose n
random points almost certainly you'll
never have three lines coincide but
setting aside the technical nuances the
problem is such a tease it looks so
convincingly like powers of two until it
just barely breaks and I have such a
strange soft spot for this particular
question when I was younger I wrote a
poem about it and also a song and on the
one hand it's kind of silly because this
is just one example of what the
mathematician Richard guy called the
strong law of small numbers summed up in
the phrase there aren't enough small
numbers to meet the many demands made of
them
but I think what I really like about
this problem is that if you sit down to
try to work out what is the real pattern
what's actually going on here one it's
just a really good exercise and problem
solving so it makes for a nice lesson
right here but also it's not just a
coincidence that it starts off being
powers of two there's a very good reason
this happens and it's also not a
coincidence that you seemingly randomly
hit another Power of Two a little bit
later on the 10th iteration
foreign
so we've got this pattern and what you
want to find is what function describes
it if you put n points on the boundary
of a circle and you connect them with
all the possible chords and you count
how many regions the circle has been cut
into if the answer isn't a power of two
what is it what function of n should we
plug in
as always with math problem solving rule
number one if you're stuck is to try
solving easier questions somehow related
to the problem at hand it helps you get
a foothold and sometimes those answers
are helpful in the final question in
this case two warm-up questions that
come to mind are how many total chords
are there in this diagram and at how
many points within the circle do those
chords intersect each other the first
question is relatively friendly every
one of those chords corresponds uniquely
with a pair of points on the circle
so effectively what you want to do is
count how many distinct pairs of points
are there
is a function that does this it's called
n choose two by definition this counts
the number of distinct pairs that you
can choose from a set of n items where
order doesn't matter to calculate it the
way you often think about it is that you
have n choices for what your first item
should be and then you have n minus 1
options for what that second item should
be
but simply multiplying those would over
count since for a given pair you would
have two distinct ways to arrive at that
pair and remember we don't care about
order to account for this you divide by
two so for example seven choose 2 would
look like seven times six divided by two
which is 7 times 3 or 21 and if you
count up the number of distinct pairs of
seven items there are indeed 21 of them
counting the number of intersection
points in the diagram is a little bit
trickier one idea might be that it
should be the number of pairs of chords
since every intersection Point comes
from two different chords however that
would not quite be right because the
association is not unique you can find a
pair of chords that don't intersect
within the circle as I said it's a
little bit tricky I'd encourage you to
try to pause and think about it for
yourself and if you do that you give
yourself a moment maybe if you're a
little bit lucky here's one thing you
might notice
every intersection point is uniquely
associated with a quadruplet of points
on the exterior
for a given quadruplet you look at the
two kind of diagonal chords between them
and those will intersect within the
circle and it goes the other way around
every intersection Point corresponds
with some quadruplet of points
so what you want now is to count how
many distinct ways can you choose four
items given n total choices
this is very similar to the previous
question the function that answers it is
called n choose 4 which by definition
counts the number of quadruplets from a
set of size n and the way to calculate
it is similar to what we saw before you
would think of having n choices for your
first item leaving you with n minus 1
choices for the next item leaving you
with n minus two choices for the third
item and N minus three choices for the
last item
that however would grossly overcount the
total number since all the different
ways you can permute these four items
would be counted separately to account
for that you divide out by the extent to
which you've over counted the number of
permutations of four items which looks
like four factorial
for example if you calculate four choose
four everything cancels and you just get
one and indeed there is a single
intersection point in this diagram
if you calculate six choose four it
works out to be fifteen
and if you look at this diagram and you
count them all up you would notice there
are indeed 15 different intersection
points
and even if you would never want to
count it up by hand if we had a diagram
that has 100 distinct points on the
exterior and we drew all of the
connecting lines you can conclude that
there have to be 100 shoes for or just
about 4 million intersection points
somewhere in the middle
you've probably guessed this but these
are more than just warm-up questions
they give us the necessary information
to answer the question we care about how
many regions has the circle been cut
into the trick is to use a very nice
little fact about planar graphs here I'm
using the word graph in the sense of a
diagram that has nodes and lines
connecting them and what it means to be
planar is that you can draw this diagram
without any of the lines intersecting
with each other in graph Theory lingo
you typically call those nodes vertices
and the lines connecting them edges and
the wonderful fact that we can Leverage
is that if you count up the number of
vertices and then you subtract the total
number of edges
and then you consider the number of
regions that this graph has cut the
plane into including that infinite outer
region then always no matter what planar
graph you started with you get two it's
actually very fun try this for yourself
draw any graph make sure the lines don't
intersect and then count the number of
vertices subtract the number of edges
and count the number of regions that
it's cut the plane into and no matter
what diagram you chose the answer always
works out to be two
more commonly you would see this written
as V minus E plus f is equal to two
since originally the equation described
the vertices edges and faces of
three-dimensional polyhedra and if you
want to know why this magical fact is
true you can think about building up
your graph from a trivial case where you
have a single node and no edges so V
would be equal to one F would also be
equal to 1 because of that infinite
outer region and E is zero so the
equation is obviously true then if you
build up your graph one Edge at a time
one thing that could happen is that for
each new Edge you introduce a new vertex
so e goes up by one but V also goes up
by one leaving the equation balanced but
if a new Edge doesn't correspond to a
new vertex meaning it's connecting to a
pre-existing vertex that means that it's
enclosed a new region of space so e goes
up by one but F also goes up by one
which again leaves the equation balanced
so as you build up some potentially
complicated graph V minus E plus F
always stays fixed at two this equation
has a name it's called Euler's
characteristic formula and I remember
when I made a video about this a while
ago I had some dumb joke in there about
eulers being German for beautiful and
there were a decent number of comments
that were like you know Euler is
actually a person I speak German and it
doesn't mean beautiful
anyway for our purposes it gives us a
tool for counting the number of regions
that a planar graph has cut space into
rearranging a little you would take the
number of edges minus the number of
vertices plus two
this is exactly the tool that we want to
understand our Circle question although
in that case we don't care about the
infinite outer region so instead I'll
write this as e minus V plus one
and at first you might complain but we
can't use Euler's formula in this case
because it only applies to planar graphs
and in our case the line's absolutely
intersect with each other we even
counted how many times they intersect
with each other but the key is to treat
this as a new graph where those
intersection points are themselves
vertices so the total number of vertices
here would not be n but n plus the N
choose four total intersection points
that in turn chops up all of our chords
into a larger number of edges it's much
more than just n choose two and
initially it might seem really annoying
and tricky to think about exactly how
much it's chopped them up but one way
you can think about it is that every
intersection Point takes what started as
two separate lines and then turns it
into four lines so in effect each
intersection Point adds two more edges
for example look at this simple diagram
where we have three lines and two
intersection points the total number of
edges after the chopping would look like
three plus two times two or seven if you
had four lines that intersected at three
separate points then the total number of
little lines after chopping would be
four plus two times three or ten and for
the diagram we care about where we
started off with n choose two separate
lines and they're getting chopped up at
n choose Four Points in the middle you
would end up with and choose two plus
two times and choose four edges and
actually there are a few more than that
because we're including the circle we
also need to count the N different arcs
that sit on the outside of this diagram
so with all of that you have the
information you need to answer the
original question pulling up our variant
of Euler's formula that counts the
number of regions we'll plug in the
expression for the number of vertices
which is n plus the N choose four
intersection points and you also plug in
the slightly larger expression for the
new number of edges and choose two plus
two times n choose four plus n and the
expression has a lot of nice
cancellation for example you are adding
an N but also subtracting an n and
you're adding two copies of entries four
but subtracting another copy of n choose
four and when all the dust settles the
answer to the question is 1 plus n
choose two plus n choose four
on the one hand you're done you answered
the question I give you one of these
Circle diagrams with endpoints on the
boundary and using this formula you can
figure out how many regions the circle
has been cut into but of course we're
not really done because that doesn't
scratch the itch why is it the case that
this looks like powers of two and then
falls short by just one it's not just a
coincidence and the key to answering it
is to consider Pascal's triangle you
know this triangle it's the one where
each term looks like a sum of the two
different terms above it and there are
basically two facts we need to bring in
about this triangle the first is that
every term inside this triangle looks
like n choose k for some value of N and
K that is the answer to the question of
how many ways can you select a subset of
size K from a set of size n is visible
within this triangle the way to think
about it is by indexing the rows and
columns starting from zero for example
if you count up to the 0 1 2 3 4 5th row
and you count in to the 0 1 2 3rd
element you see ten and indeed five
choose 3 is equal to 10. if you've never
seen this before and you want to know
why it's true there's a really lovely
argument I'll leave it up as an exercise
but moving on to the second thing that
we need to know notice what happens when
you add up the rows of this triangle you
get one and then one plus one is two one
plus two plus one is four one plus three
plus three plus one is eight and as you
continue on you always get powers of two
maybe at this point you're a little gun
shy about jumping to conclusions about
powers of two too quickly but in this
case it's a genuine pattern there's no
trickery being pulled and there are a
few ways that you can think about why
there should be powers of two here but
one that I like is to think about how as
you go from that first row to the next
one it's like the number one is sort of
donating two copies of itself into the
next row
likewise as you go from the second row
to the third each of those ones is
donating two copies of itself to the
next row and in general as you go from
one row to the next each number donates
two copies of itself to the one below so
as you add up the totals for each of
these rows it stands to reason that
those totals double on each iteration
circling back to our original question
think about what this means the answer
to our question looked like one plus n
choose two plus n choose four in the
context of Pascal's triangle you could
think about that as adding up the zeroth
second and fourth terms inside some row
of that triangle
for instance when n is equal to 5 it
looks like adding up one plus ten plus
five now because each of those numbers
is the sum of the two above it this is
the same thing as adding up the first
five elements in the previous row which
in this case is adding up the entire
previous row hence why it's a power of
two same deal for all the numbers that
are five or less when you situate this
formula inside Pascal's triangle and you
relate it to the previous row what
you're doing is adding up the entirety
of that previous row
the point at which this breaks is for n
equals six because in that case when you
relate this to the previous row adding
up the first five elements of that row
it doesn't cover the whole thing it
falls short specifically by just one
which is why we missed the power of two
and why it falls short specifically by
just one also notice what happens when
we plug in n equals 10. looking down at
the tenth row and relating those terms
to the previous one adding the first
five elements of the ninth row is
exactly half of that row and because the
triangle is symmetric this means that
when you add them up you get exactly
half of a power of two which itself of
course is another Power of Two And as a
challenge problem for you I don't
actually know if this is the last time
that you'll ever see a power of two
maybe one of you out there who's clever
with diophantine equations than I am can
come up with some clever proof
stepping back to summarize we started by
counting the total number of chords and
the total number of intersection points
which by thinking about the right
associations is the same as Computing n
choose 2 and N choose 4. bringing in
Euler's formula this let us get an exact
closed form expression for the number of
regions inside the circle then
connecting that with Pascal's triangle
gives us a very visceral connection with
the powers of two and why they break
when they do
so yes moser's Circle problem is a
cautionary tale about being wary of
patterns without proof but at a deeper
level it also tells us that what
sometimes chalked up to be coincidence
still leaves room for satisfying
understandings
[Music]
by the way the summer of math Exposition
is indeed happening again this year if
you have any interest in making an
online math explainer of some form
whether that's a video or an article or
anything else you dream up the last two
years have proven that this is a great
way to get more eyes on your work and
also there are opportunities for cash
prizes thanks to the generosity of this
year's sponsor Jane Street you can find
all the information you need at
sum.3b1b.co and I'll also leave other
relevant links in the description so do
check them out it was a ton of fun the
last two years and I'm very excited to
see what people come up with this year
foreign
[Music]